good to see you both congratulations on
this movie
you're you're the action duo
and i love that we get to see all that
and for my money
you got you're the best fighters on the
eternals that's i gotta say that for a
fact
but between the two of you between
theena and gilgamesh who would you say
is the better fighter like who has the
better moves
of course tina i'd say
we can't we can't fight each other it's
impossible but she's a goddess of war
you know you know what that means
it's impossible
we are we're too we're perfectly what's
beautiful is it's intentional we are
equally matched yeah
yes i love it and another thing that i i
find fantastic and what's very
intentional on this
is that
the eternals are reflecting this broad
scope of what it means to be human even
though they're not human but the human
experience goes way beyond what we've
experienced in marvel movies before
angelina what does it mean to be part of
this project where you're bringing
all of those different things
to
the marvel cinematic universe it was the
main reason i wanted to do it
and um
it's
really you know we thought we'd come on
and it would feel this unique special
thing that we were bringing forward and
really it just felt right
it just felt like this is how it of
course it is it didn't feel unusual or
special it felt
this this is how the world really is and
this is this just feels absolutely
natural and correct and and uh but but
yes of course we know that there are so
many people that have never seen
themselves
and been represented as a superhero who
should have been
and will now have that and this for many
people who
have faced abuses because of their
sexual preferences or being different in
different ways or different races
i hope this gives them that little bit
more more uh
i hope they see themselves and they just
hold their heads up that little bit
higher and know how
you know that we are all equal and
special and they see it yeah it's not
about race it's just
uh it's about who we are as an
individual
and the relationship between your
characters is very special as well um
the way it plays out don you
take it upon yourself gilgamesh does to
become tina's protector when she goes
through her the you know eternal version
of the dementia that she is experiencing
how does that affect
their relationship having known each
other for thousands of years
well he's a
he's a very eyes he's a protector he's
he was he's very protective of his
eternal family and human
uh and then
uh
i mean
it's it's it's really hard to explain
because they live so long but uh
their relationship is just more than
friendship is
we can't really imagine how deep their
uh uh relationship is it's literally
it's gonna be a little different and
that he
he will do
he'll do anything anything to protect
her
that's
that's one of his roles so
yeah
and angelina how did you embrace this
when it came to preparing to play tina
well i'm
on the on the action side i decided to
study ballet
because i wanted her to be as feminine
as possible and i thought that was
important to bring my femininity also
knowing i would be with dawn so he would
bring masculine strength and bring the
female strength and we'd kind of come
together
um
and then a lot of practice with
imaginary weapons so real weapons
imaginary switching out because my
weapons are constantly switching
um
emotionally it was quite it was quite um
not hard it was it was
it was
it was it was very challenging to play
somebody who is both
the most powerful person and the
strongest fighter and extremely broken
almost like a child who has um is
suffering mental health issues so
i love that those two things are in the
same person i believe they exist in the
same person and many of us
um you're neither strong nor broken
we're all
but uh
but i i found it a challenge to
to put
would people see her as strong when they
also see her completely broken can you
can they and uh and i think i think you
can yep
well i love that dynamic and i love the
2u1 screen together thank you so much
for your time oh thank you